Food has a language.
Food allowed me to
become an artist.
What I want to do is
to invite you to really
understand and appreciate
vegetables on a deeper level.
I don't like the
convention of things,
but I do things because
I want change to happen.
La salade de melons.
I'm gonna show you how to make
vegetarian recipes at home
to impress your
family and friends.
Are you guys ready?
Mmm.
Whether you're a meat
eater, a vegetarian,
this class is for you.
I'm gonna show you
how to peel asparagus.
Hold the asparagus here at the
tip so you don't crush the tip.
I will say you
undress the asparagus.
[CHUCKLES] So good.
Mmm.
Wow.
All right, so we are
grilling the melon.
Oh yeah.
It's OK if you get messy.
Your hands kind of
smell like garlic,
so I just put a little
bit of lemon on my hand.
This is not about perfection.
Just wash it like this.
It's about deliciousness.
My restaurant, Atelier Crenn,
means workshop in English.
Oh yeah, this is good.
A place where you
bring your creativity.
Beautiful.
If you want to
become a cook, you
have to understand
where things come from.
Get to know your farmers.
Cook local.
When you have the best
ingredients-- voila,
La Tomate, tu jardin.
then you can do
the best cooking.
Doesn't matter your
experiences in the kitchen,
I'm inviting you to think
differently about food.
Je m'appelle Dominique
Crenn, et c'est MasterClass.